IT'S TIME TO PLAY SCARE BNB.
SCARE BNB.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: AIRBNB OFFERS PEOPLES
HOMES FOR TO STAY AT A FRACTION
OF THE COST OF THE HOTEL.
IT'S A GREAT RESOURCE FOR
TRAVELS WHO WANT TO SAVE MONEY
AND OFTEN THINK TODAY IS A GOOD
DAY TO DIE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
AN PICTURE FROM AN AIRBNB
LISTING, AND FOR 250 POINTS GIVE
ME A TAGLINE TO ADVERTISE IT.
FIRST ONE: THIS RETIRED CABOOSE
$20.
SEEMS FINE. HORATIO.
>> DO IT IN MY CABOOSE.
>> CHRIS: OH PERFECT!
POIINTS. RICH.
>> I THINK I CAN, I THINK I CAN
-- SURVIVE!
>> CHRIS: YEAH. POINTS.
GOOD.
BRETT.
>> ONLY FIVE MURDERS AND THREE
RAPES LAST YEAR.
>> CHRIS: JESUS CHRIST.
>> NO, NO.
ALL VICTIMS WERE STRAIGHT
WEALTHY WHITE MEN.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, GOOD POINTS.
THAT MAKES IT OKAY.
NEXT ONE.
THIS BNB MASSACRING AS A
LAUNDROMAT. $39.
THIRTY -- OH MY GOD.
THOSE ARE WEIRD PRISON TUBES
FROM THE FUTURE.
ANYONE. BRETT.
>> STAY IN THE SAME BED THAT
80S STAR ET DIED OF A SPEED-BALL
OVERDOSE LAST YEAR.
>> CHRIS: THIS IS WHERE ET DIED.
>> YA.
CHRIS: HORATIO.
>> HI I NEED A WAKE-UP CALL FOR
TEN THOUSAND YEARS FROM NOW.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ALSO POINTS TO BRETT GELMAN FOR
THE OTHER ONE. RICH FULCHER.
>> HOPE YOU LIKE CREAM CORN
BECAUSE AT TWO AM EVERY NIGHT
CORKY PIPE THAT'S [BEEP] IN!
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> HOW IS CORKY BY THE WAY.
>> CORKY IS DOING WELL.
HIS FAMILY TREE IS A STRAIGHT
LINE.
>> CHRIS: GOOD.
NEXT ONE.
THIS -- THIS LEAN-TUBE-THING.
YOU CAN STAY THERE FOR $82.
HORATIO.
>> HOBO [BEEP] SHACK.
CHRIS: IN MURDER-ADJACENT WOODS.
YEAH, BRETT.
>> BELIEVE IN BIGFOOT? DON'T
LIKE GETTING A GOOD NIGHT SLEEP.
STAY HERE, YOU STUPID ASSHOLE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. RICH FULCHER.
>> FUN FACT THIS WAS THE
UNI-BOMBER'S FIRST APARTMENT.
>> CHRIS: NICE. POINTS.
HOW ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A SELF DESCRIBED WOMB
ROOM.
$188. $188.
YOU KNOW, THE WORST OFFENSE IN
THERE IS THAT GUYS [BEEP] VEST.
THAT'S WORST THAN EVERYTHING
ELSE THERE.
THAN THAT WEIRD MURDEROUS
ARK OF THE COVENANT.
BRETT GELAMAN
>> THIS WOMB ROOM COMES WITH
THESE TWO GUYS.
ADDED BONUS ONLY ONE OF THEM
WILL JERK OFF ON YOU.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
YES, RICH.
>> BE SENT TO EARTH BEFORE
CRYPTON EXPLODES.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.